everybody here plays guitar everybody
that in this whole place could pick up a
guitar play a song cuz everybody plays
and sings
I'm here to learn about the music of
this place my job in a way is it's kind
of like a chef and I have to learn a
local cuisine and get familiar with all
the flavors of it so that I can blend
them together and make a tasty dish I
think the most satisfaction in a project
like this is the early stages
we're in Syrah which is the biggest city
here in this part of Opera so far the
trip for me has been looking for stuff
this kind of unusual trying to find
things that are threads that will
eventually be woven into the fabric of
I'm going to have these guys do a
variety of different things different
grooves so I can just have little snips
that's good Saturday we're gonna go to
swing through
there was a little clip that I got a
video clip that Gregg good shot of Joey
singing a song of a little uh ukulele
song and it gave me some sort of
parameters of what I was looking to
write a lot of what I'm going to try to
do is make a library of music so that
when they're looking for a piece of
music for the film maybe a sad part
it may be Jawi song done mournfully Joey
father had been actually killed in a
fishing accident his uncle Josiah
adopted him and had brought him up since
he was just a small baby and it turns
out that you SIA is this very important
figure who is well known throughout Raja
Ampat because he's a musician and a
dancer
it's so lucky to find this guy he really
is the real deal
no it's really real musical and it's
just he's a poet
you just got tremendous energy both
physical and mental this is what I was
hoping to find here is somebody who just
is a member of this world and not trying
to prove anything not trying to show off
he's just expressing his spirit through
his music
I get to go around and meet a lot of
people constantly learning things
constantly getting more comfortable with
the fact that I don't know things and
enthusiastic to try to learn something
else and maybe mix something together in
an organic way that comes up with
something that's it's at least new to me
and hopefully new to other people